on Prime crime hi we here for a missing
person's report a night out for a mother
of three ends in tragedy her injuries
were brutal it was so bad that they
couldn't ID her but identifying a killer
when I interview someone what I want to
do is give them the opportunity to talk
becomes a complicated task thank you
guys so nobody that's your Alibi your
Alibi is the guy that's for murder
that's what you're going to walk out
this door with as we move from one
suspect right now I'm going to be taking
you into custody to another so obviously
you're brought here handcuffs right um
which means you're
[Music]
arrested hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber
and welcome to Prime crime where we
break down some of the most compelling
Ing and memorable True Crime cases back
in 2016 a woman goes out for the evening
to have some fun but the night takes a
very dark turn this is the case that you
may think is easy to solve but as we're
about to show you the answers are
sometimes not right in front of you
Brown County public safety yes um how do
I go about I guess uh missing
person in May 2016 now in Green Bay
Wisconsin a 9911 phone call begins a new
case who's missing uh it's my girlfriend
and she she does live with me and she's
never done this before what's her name
Nicole sander Heiden Nicole vanderhyden
was a mother of three was a substitute
teacher and was described by most of the
people in her life as someone who really
enjoyed life she was described as
someone who had a best for Life enjoyed
the outdoors and a holistic lifestyle
and what's your name Doug last name Doug
and Nikki had been in a relationship
they had been in a relationship for some
time they had had a child together
officer Shield arrive at Berkeley Road
on May 21st 2016 completing a missing
person's report hi
there oh okay yeah hi hi
hello hi we here for a missing person's
report time becomes critical in a
missing person's case and one of the
first things investigators need to do is
to understand the sequence of events
leading up to a
disappearance what's going on uh haven't
uh seen no nobody's seen or heard from
her since last night I'd say
like midnight Nicole vanderhyden was
with her boyfriend dou D Tree and they
were out with a group of friends we were
actually on the west side at the
watering hole I was on my way down there
and she was down at the Sardine Can with
some other friends of mine actually what
is it called the sand lot or whatever it
was a concert there and that was over
with and then I'd spoke with her and she
was already in the car with my friends
headed down to the s c where we were all
going to go down during the evening they
had a disagreement and became separated
my friend Aon saw her she was upset and
walking away down south on Maple Street
so before you even got down to the
Sardine Can he text you that she just
stormed off South on Maple Street he
talked to her in the car and she was all
mad who's
he okay what was she mad
about I don't know she said I was
talking to a girl who I have no idea
were you guys drinking yes Doug's
intoxicated Nicole's intoxicated
obviously alcohol is a contributing
factor you're not making the best
decisions because we're not thinking and
acting the same way I was still at the
watering pole and wondering where she
was and cuz we were going to go on to
the next place cuz the show was over and
um that's when I talked to her and she
was with a couple of my other friends
rid with them that was actually on the
phone it was did you call her
conversation she called you I called her
she was angry at Doug because she
thought that he was flirting with other
people that night there wasn't a
seamless relationship between the two
there had been some static in the
relationship some arguments
historically we had actually talked to
her I was call her on the way down you
actually talk to her I talk to her she's
mad she's walking she was trying to get
her to tell us where she was I thought
maybe if I was talking to her instead of
Doug that maybe she would let me know
where she was and let us come pick her
up so she's not just wandering the
streets yeah she didn't believe that I
wasn't Doug talking to her then she hung
up okay and then every time we tried to
call her again her phone just went
to Nikki went to the Sardine Can and dug
a KN at least not right away and that's
where law enforcement kind of ran into a
little bit of a dead end because the
last video that they had of Nikki was
leaving the Sardine Can and they didn't
know where she went
next did you see her walking no we drove
up and down the streets for a while
trying to find
and then we went back to the Sardine Can
thinking maybe she walked back there and
then we asked people around the Sardine
Can if they had seen her what time did
you guys get home 2 2:30 maybe Doug then
went home and relieved the babysitter
and took care of his child and he
reported that he was hung over the next
day and assumed that she had been as
well so while he was concerned that she
hadn't shown up he wasn't so concerned
at that point to make a a missing
person's report or alert authorities it
wasn't until some time later that he
actually did report her missing to the
police is it normal for her to sleep off
being angry at you somewhere else is
that normal no even when she's been
upset with me um still will maintain
contact we had had text messages from
that night that were very indicative
that there was
issues she told you where she was at but
she was definitely upset at that time
I'm thinking maybe she saw you talk yeah
she had sent me a text saying that that
she was upset with you yeah can I see
the text why is she calling you abusive
I I don't know as we learn more into the
case the relationship maybe wasn't what
had seemed between Nikki and Doug Doug
had allegations of abuse against him in
the past the fighting that had happened
before obviously was of concern to law
enforcement investigators then bring
Doug in for more questioning what time
do you leave the watering hole then I
didn't leave I don't know I I'm guessing
our all
msh a little laugh I was pretty
intoxicated at that point the first
person we are going to look at is the
significant other they're the closest to
the person a lot of times they're the
easiest to eliminate um depending on
their Alibi and the evidence that we see
how long do you think you drove around
looking for before you went to the
certain Camp I yeah I don't know 10
minutes I I don't know this whole time
you were driving around looking for her
were you either calling and or texting
her yeah when I interview someone what I
want to do is give them the opportunity
to talk I'm looking at body language
how's the person reacting what do you
think happened or where do you think she
may have gone any idea to be honest I
don't know she I think she just could
have just walked on I think she might
went to another bar a lot of times I'm
going to ask questions that I already
know the answer to to see if they are
being truthful or find any type of
Deceit at some point this morning you
woke up and must have been kind of
freaking out that she wasn't home yet
yeah it's always hard to judge people
especially when they're going through
something traumatic my initial read from
it was it just seemed like somewhat of a
lack of emotion to some extent did you
at any time think about getting out and
going looking for her yeah uh well
that's when Greg was I got a hold of
Greg and he said can you give me a ride
to my car and I and I had while Dylan so
I um had asked my parents to come over
and watch them in this time period I get
more and more worried talking to people
not finding any
answers investigators put their
attention on drie particularly since he
didn't report Nicole missing until the
following afternoon but is he the one
responsible for Nicole's
disappearance so Friday was the last
time that her vehicle left your
residence y you haven't driven at all
this week weekend
no this case is about to change when
police receive another 911 phone call BR
County 911 what does the address of your
emergency in it's just about by the
corner of bellw and is that Alaway
Avenue where they criss
cross uh we just found a human body
laying in some Wheats oh God we're clear
in a field here and we just ran across
it there was a farmer that had been
picking rocks in a field with his family
and they had discovered a body in the
field that was kind of in the
woods when we return what happened to
Nicole vanderheiden the answers may not
be what you
[Music]
think you don't have any kind of
injuries anywhere or
anything I mean like scratch something
that would look like you no would you
consider Nikki to be a scrapper a
fighter no I mean she to hold her own
I in 2016 Green Bay Wisconsin
authorities are trying to find out what
happened to Nicole vanderhyden a mother
and teacher they questioned her
boyfriend and father of one of her kids
Douglas dietre who had been out with
Nicole the night of her disappearance
but separated from her when the two
began to argue however the day after she
went missing police receive a startling
call is the person beyond help or do I
need to give instructions for CPR no
it's beyond help it's starting is it a
male or a female it's got long
hair this body that was found okay down
the street I don't think it's been 100%
identified as her but there's a lot of
similarities what do you mean a lot of
similarities the physical description
height blonde belly button
ring in a tragic turn of events that
body was positively identified as Nicole
vanderheiden she had suffered from
strangulation in blunt force trauma to
the head and there was indication of
sexual
assault her injuries were brutal it was
so bad that they couldn't ID her they
had to formally identify her through
dental records she had bruises all over
her body I believe it was over 200 uh
different bruises what happened well I
don't know that's what we're trying to
figure out and off duty Deputy found a
bunch of clothing that was just on the
side of the road and that happened to be
her personal belongings some of her
clothes maybe a purse discarded right
there on the highway near where her body
was found it was near her house the
suspect in this case committed these
horrific crimes chokes her and then is
in probably in panic mode realizing that
I need at least distance some of the
evidence from the body you haven't
talked to Aaron yet we're working on it
why are you so concerned that we talked
to Aaron well he's the last person I've
seen her that I know I want to know at
least his story is Dre in mhm so
basically what we know right now is what
you've told us now investigators focus
more on drie did you do anything to
cause her to go missing no not not at
all drives being a on a phone well the
next step in this is to search your
house okay uh and her car all right well
I understand that so there was a search
warrant written for your house okay and
they're headed over there and I want to
search your hes okay in these types of
situations the person that's closest to
them they have the most to gain when
they go search your house is there
anything in there that they're going to
find that's going to say you at anything
abs nothing
whatsoever nothing I have nothing to do
with this I
mean however law enforcement does find
something at the home that dietry shared
with
vanderheiden there was blood found in
the garage there was a footprint or a
shoe print found on Nicole that looked
similar to the tread of a sneaker that
was found within the residence there was
also what appeared to be blood on that
sneaker there was actually a neighbor
that had been cutting his grass and he
had hit something with his lawnmower
they had found a afay cord that was
believed to be one of the murder weapons
when you put that all together
ultimately the crime scene was right
there in front of their
house Slinger with white on Monday May
23rd attempting contact with Doug dri at
his family's residents why don't we step
outside quick okay here's the deal DG
right now I'm going to be taking you
into custody be handcuffing you I I'll
explain all that to you in a bit um and
transporting you down to the Sheriff's
Department okay okay so just be
cooperative with me and we'll roll it
that way wow okay all
right forensic evidence the fighting and
failing to call 911 for hours after
Nicole's disappearance all lead to to
authorities arresting Douglas dietre at
one point in the investigation law
enforcement interviewed diet's friend
Greg Matthew we were trying to determine
if you're really truly trying to help us
or if there's something a Miss Doug is
providing a story Doug is with us I mean
so that's kind of a big deal isn't it
right now he's with
us Matthew had been with dietre on the
night that Nicole was killed but he's
Adam and he played no role in what
happened whatever the issue was with
Doug and Nicole that night I don't think
that it was pre-planned I don't want
think it was something that was
malicious not only do I not think that
Doug wanted this to occur but I
especially don't think that you wanted
this to occur honestly I had
absolutely absolutely nothing to to do
with what what did you have nothing to
do with anything to do with what did you
have nothing to do
with not she Nikki again after she left
the watering hole I absolutely did not
see her again the evidence shows that
your friend Doug had involvement in her
murder there's no doubt about it I tried
to help you guys as much as I can I've
been thinking about this timeline for
the last 72 hours can you tell me what
you could possibly think that we would
have found at his house that would cause
Doug to be with us no idea I would hope
that you have been able to find anything
at his house because I would imagine I
would hope that he had nothing to do
with this and that's when Matthew has
had
enough I never saw Nikki again I left
the house while Dallas was the
babysitter was still there who can vouch
for you for the 60 minutes before you
showed up and made contact with Dallas
who can vouch for where you were if your
phone is dead thank you guys so nobody
that's your Alibi your Alibi is the guy
that's a custody for murder that's what
you're going to walk out this door with
when you are starting to accuse me of
being involved in this in any way I want
to accuse you of being involved yes you
are you're telling me Oh it'll make you
feel better if you told us the truth
I've been telling you the truth dark
diso is nothing to me he is kept to his
innocence every single time I've talked
to him so if he's in custody for murder
then and he's being framed if Doug was
involved in something like this would
you tell you if he had any involvement
in it and he better not because if he
told me he had any involvement in it I
would tell you guys
immediately that is an interesting
question do authorities have the right
person in custody did Douglas dietry
kill Nicole vanderhyden when we return a
new player comes into the mix how does
this I I have no idea how this goes I
mean well I'll kind of explain
everything to you once we get out there
because you requested an attorney we
obviously are respecting that I was
advised so I mean I got my family
they're very concerned
that I know what the truth
[Music]
is how does this work with the attorney
know I just it's your right to request
an attorney how do I I didn't even
determine if I want which one I wanted
or anything like that Wisconsin man
Douglas dietry is arrested in connection
with the murder of his living girlfriend
Nicole vanderhyden the night of her
disappearance she had fought with drie
and the forensic evidence indicates she
was killed outside their home while it
may appear police have their man not so
fast there's something that dri had been
wearing that would ultimately save his
life I'm a decent guy I'm a decent guy
too I get that I'm sure you are um you
seem like a real nice guy the other
one's good this one kind of got caught
up on Fitbit or what yeah investigators
noticed right away that Doug was wearing
a Fitbit during their initial
investigation the data showed that Doug
was not mobile at the time that n had
gone missing and her body was disposed
of in a nearby area it showed that Doug
was at his residence during the time
that Nicole had been missing as part of
another piece of essentially an alibi
there was a aggressive snapshot on
Nikki's car the vehicle had not moved a
lot of the evidence initially pointed to
him but it was ultimately a red herring
because when they later investigated the
blood that was found in his home and on
the sneaker it wasn't actually Nicole's
blood Doug had gone turkey hunting some
time before her disappearance there was
no physical evidence linking Doug to
Nicole's disappearance or to her
death with that dietre is cleared as a
suspect and is released after his arrest
so the question becomes again who killed
Nicole vanderheiden a closer look at the
forensics from Nicole's crime scene
takes investigators in a New Direction
when they found her body in the field
she was wearing one sock DNA was found
on that lone piece of clothing on her
body the DNA that was found on Nicole's
sock was run through the system and it
was later revealed to be identified as
belonging to George
Birch George
Steve stand for me I'm just going to
check your packets one more time and
I'll see the handcuffs off you you don't
have anything on you no pocket knes or
anything oh George Steven Burch a then
38-year-old who moved from Virginia to
Green Bay Wisconsin so how about 6 67
260 roughly once burch's DNA came up law
enforcement did surveillance and watched
Birch and followed his movements and
they later realized that he had been
involved in a hit-and run accident he
said that he hadn't been involved and he
said that his phone data would
ultimately prove that he wasn't involved
in that hit and run so he had given
consent to search his phone what's your
phone number
oh Google dashboard was used to find out
exactly where Birch was located and it
uses cell phone tower data and so
Birch's phone was in front of Nicole's
Residence at one point and then later
where her body was ultimately recovered
his data points placed him in all these
key points where they had found that key
evidence where they had found the
clothes dumped on the highway so all of
a sudden they were able to pinpoint that
George was in all of those
locations so obviously you're brought
your handcuffs right um which means
you're arrested the reason you're here
is in reference to homicide
investigation into Nicole Vander heid it
okay so is this something that you want
to talk to me about yes sir about that
you don't want to talk to me about that
so if I read you Miranda rites you don't
you don't want to talk to me so I prefer
a lawyer and after Burch is arrested
investigators conduct another test GE
remember me from before investigator
Slinger as part of this investigation we
have a search warrant signed by a judge
um which you'll be allow to bring back
yourself for your DNA so I ask that you
cooperate with the process basically
what I do is just do a swabbing of your
inner cheek on each side you open your
mouth for me Birch's DNA profile match
swabs taken from the victim's ankles
right wrist right forearm right hand
fingernail clippings left arm left palm
and nons sperm vagin and cervical swabs
additionally testing showed that Birch's
DNA was found on the cord that was
ultimately used to kill Nicole despite
the fact that George's DNA was found on
Nicole's body he consistently denied
that he had anything to do with her
murder bur is charged with the murder of
Nicole vanderheiden do authorities have
the right man this time and what does
Birch say happened when we returned turn
his Unforgettable testimony from trial
did you put her in the vehicle
eventually yes sir I was advised to shut
the door and then I was advised to get
in the vehicle you say you were advised
by this individual what was their
demeanor like threatening pretty much
forceful uh letting me know that this is
what I want you to do and you're going
to do
[Music]
it
what's going to happen now is uh I'm
going to call for a squad and you're
going to be transported to the jail I
will give you a business card of mine to
go with you and if you change your mind
at any time that um you wish to speak to
me you'll have the avenue to do that
it's February 2018 out in Green Bay
Wisconsin a televised trial is beginning
in the 2016 murder of mother of three
and teacher Nicole vanderheiden whose
body was found in a field after a night
out when she's separated from her
friends and boyfriend prosecutors say a
stranger George bir brutally killed
vanderhyden after meeting her earlier
that evening who has been proven to have
been with Nicki in the last hours of her
life whose DNA is on her sock the sock
he left behind on her battered body he's
with her in her last moments the Google
dashboard who's with Nikki at the four
key areas of Brown County defendant's
phone continues to track him continues
to place him and continues to implicate
him it puts him on the murder scene on
Berkeley it places the defendant at the
field on Hoffman where he dumps her body
his phone tracks him to where he
disposes of her clothing and her
personal
belongings the strongest evidence
against Birch was the physical DNA and
the phone d that showed the location of
the phone or by extension him on the
night that Nicole was missing I also see
law enforcement and the district
attorney making sure that their case is
airtight so that it makes it through an
appeals process and that the appeal was
denied the prosecution called Douglas
dietre Nicole's boyfriend and father of
their son who at one point was actually
a suspect in her murder until forensic
and digital evidence cleared him
including the the use of his Fitbit that
tracked his steps how was she with Dylan
and her other kids uh she was a very
good mother that's one part I liked a
lot about her was just H caring and you
know she did everything that the kids
needed and taught them well Doug was one
of the lead prosecution witnesses he
seemed to be honest he seemed to deliver
with integrity and he did not appear to
be overly prepared how would you
describe your relationship with Nikki it
was uh very very good for a lot of it we
did have uh you know little arguments
here and there but Bo had plans for
future and everything like that you know
we had talked about marriage and
everything like that he admitted when he
didn't know certain facts and he also
conceded negative points the arguments
between he and Nicole text messages
between the two of them and all of these
concessions of negative points helps to
show show Doug's honesty do you have
absolutely any involvement in Nikki's
disappearance or death uh no I did not I
think that the state wanted to paint
their relationship and Doug's initial
direct testimony was that they had a
very good relationship he had testified
about how he envisioned them walking
down the aisle together from the defense
perspective we were pointing the finger
at
him the facts show you that Doug dietry
committed this crime Justice for Nicole
is not going to be delivered by a
wrongful conviction of George bur Doug
dri had the motive the opportunity and
the connection the cross-examination
during the trial was trying to get into
that they had been fighting that the
relationship maybe wasn't what it seemed
between Nikki and Doug it was showing
that maybe that there was issues between
them in May of 2016 were you closer to
breaking up with Nikki or closer to Mary
Nikki um I would say I mean in between
there was you know we had some arguments
about a few minor things how about when
you told her I'm very seriously thinking
about telling Nikki and the kids they
have to move I'm not cut out for this
life one bit I was having a you know
little Downer day or whatever and um I
just said that to my mom with not truly
meaning it I guess I think the first day
we were able to paint that he had the
motive when did you start receiving the
text messages from Nikki what text
messages are you referring to the
messages that Nikki sent to you were she
started so what you with and then when
she said you abusive those text messages
the second day was more effective of
really getting our Theory my cross
started to focus of just all the
opportunities all the red flags that
were raised of there was something a
miss here Nikki was not home you didn't
call police right away because he
already knew where she was he had
committed the crime so roughly that's 8
hours since you had saw Nikki you did
not call the police at 6:30 no you did
not call Nicole's sister at 6:30 no you
did not call Nicole's mother at 6:30 uh
no I did not you just went back to bed
yeah I was tired I was hung over and
then you woke up again around 11: I yeah
I think approximately 11:00 and now it
had been 12 hours since you had last
seen Nikki she still wasn't home for
Dylan no she was not did you search for
Nikki on foot or by vehicle uh no I did
not still didn't call the police I did
not at that time no cuz you knew you
didn't have to I don't know what you're
I mean I was starting to get uh
concerned but then something major
happens during the trial something that
could change whether the jury finds
George bur guilty bur himself decides to
testify that's always his choice and his
call in terms of George's case part of a
pre-trial motion to point the finger at
an accused Doug of committing this crime
was that a lot of the story was coming
from George himself just explaining what
he had gone through and it's that story
that kept viewers glued to their
screens roughly a little bit after 11 I
went to Richard CR right down the street
said hi to a lot of the usuals that knew
me asked me how I was doing everything
like that um when I went to the bar at
some point when you were there um did
you end up
meeting someone who you now know is
Nicole vanderheiden yes sir we learned
that she went to Richard craniums which
is another bar right down the road in
the Broadway District here in Green Bay
where she eventually Met George
Burch I noticed it was fairly attractive
blonde woman standing next to me started
talking to her just making conversation
she was by herself did she give you any
indication that she was actively in a
relationship not that I could tell no
sir how were you acting towards her I
was flirting and how was she acting
towards you same somewhat the same
pretty much um starting back and forth
with each other he had met Nicki they
had talked they had hit it off he didn't
know who she was but he was attracted to
her and they were going to go back to
his house and ultimately the people that
he was living with were awake so he
didn't want to go in there at all Nikki
had brought him back to her house did
you go in her residence no sir she said
there was a light on that she thought
the babysitter was still up what
happened after that started just pulling
around messing around a little bit
started kissing did you guys stay in the
front seat um no sir where'd you go uh
the back seat did you have intercourse
eventually yes
would you describe this as I guess
gentle intercourse um no sir police
testified that Birch's DNA was found on
Nicole's body and that there was nons
sperm DNA that was found suggesting that
there was a sexual encounter but not
conclusive whether it was consensual or
rape he claims that he had a consensual
sexual relationship with her in the back
of the vehicle they both were largely
nuded in the middle of the street in
front of her residence which her family
members found that would be difficult to
believe knowing
Nicole that's when this story takes a
shocking turn what ended up happening
the next thing that I remember apart
from us having intercourse was literally
waking up on the
ground outside the truck laying in the
like grass curb area I didn't know what
was going on I look down and I'm laying
on the ground and my pants are around my
ankles literally behind me something
kind of I wouldn't say hit me but nudged
me and made me aware that I was not the
only person there did you hear anything
the first thing I heard
was don't think about it I
saw what looked like a man standing with
a firearm in his hand it was fairly dark
um I saw someone that looked like a like
a hooded sweatshirt uh couldn't really
see any faces just glimps as they were
becoming intimate suddenly he was hit
with something and when he started to
come to he had noticed that there was
somebody that he didn't know had a gun
he didn't know where he was he didn't
know what was happening other than he
was terrified for his life I was
instructed
to move to the back end of the vehicle I
noticed someone or something laying in
the backs behind the truck or behind the
Blazer and I realized that it
was the cola there did you know if she
was alive or dead at that point I didn't
know if she was alive um there was a lot
of blood I was pretty much obstructed to
or told to pick her up
did you reluctantly yes were you able to
tell whether she was alive or dead I
wasn't
certain but um it definitely didn't
didn't look like she was so once you you
pict her up what happened I was
obstructed to carry her and put her in
the vehicle it truly was a fantastic
story but George's story from that night
also really did fit the evidence in a
way it explained why he was at these
places why his DNA was where it was I
was pretty much instructed to go around
the back of the
vehicle around to my driver's side when
I got in the the driver's seat he had
got in the passenger seat behind me and
shut the door be completely I just
remember I was told directions on which
way to go and where to turn this person
with a gun forced him to put Nicki's
body in his vehicle cuz he was the
person driving this person um brought
him to a field to essentially drop off
Nikki's body when they had thrown the
body where it was found in the field it
was kind of in a there was a steep
incline he was able just to make a break
for it cuz he thought he was going to be
killed that's when I turned and with
everything I had I lunged at him and
pushed him as hard as I possibly could
he stumbled backwards I broke for it ha
ass to my car did you get back on the
PVE Road yes sir where he came from you
didn't talk to police you didn't let
them know anything so he was he was
scared he was terrified is what he said
that's why he never called police did
you ever see this individual's face the
best physical image of this face was
when I looked in my rearview mirror when
I first started driving did you know who
that individual was never seen him
before in my life do you know who that
individual is now who's that be the
defense attorneys their whole theory in
this Tri was that Doug did it the best
evidence that would steer away from bir
was that he lacked a motive we do know
that Nicole and Doug actually had an
argument that night and typically
domestic
situations domestic anger jealousy those
usually fuel these types of interactions
that result in untimely death our
biggest hurdle I think was trying to
explain to the jury that even if it's
it's a fantastic or an unbelievable
story that doesn't mean that it didn't
happen and if it was reasonably possible
they're supposed to return a verdict of
not
guilty but before the jury would have
the opportunity to decide the
prosecution had some questions for bur
in your version of the events you're
assaulted you're held at gunpoint
carried the mangled body of a woman to
her final resting place and the next day
you're going fishing with your body with
a smile on your face and not a care in
the world um it was a pre-planned event
sir and I wouldn't say not a care in the
world he was very self assured and
thought that he would be able to explain
away this situation when you look at the
actual testimony he testifies relatively
well isn't it true that you didn't tell
law enforcement about this cuz you
didn't think anybody was going to
believe this story no sir not at all you
thought that this was a perfectly
logical reasonable story that anybody
would believe it's the truth so rather
than just beating you or killing you in
the middle of the streat he decided to
enlist you a total stranger to help him
dispose of the body of his girlfriend I
don't know what his plans were you know
I thought on Direct he did really well
and then when the district attorney was
cross-examining him there's a part where
the prosecutor specifically was getting
loud and getting hostile on
cross-examination in a professional
appropriate way and George's response
was equally
hostile and it becomes clear that Nikki
isn't going to have sex with you when
she attempts to go into her house and
leave your vehicle that's when your mood
changes right no sir that's when things
get aggressive don't they not at all
that's when you grab that cord and
strangle her don't you no sir not at all
that's when Nikki gets slammed on the
ground repeatedly when she's trying to
run toward her house when those blood
stains lead in a direction back to her
home none of that is true well how do
you know you were out cold when Nikki
was assulted cuz you said I did it I
think you could argue well he's under
the most stressful time in his life so
you can't blame him for that but that's
one moment that it was just like you
felt it in your throat a little bit of
like oh I wish that wouldn't have
happened Nikki was strangled she had a
fractured jaw correct I don't know sir
that's what the medical examiner said
you saw her injuries you said through
Court to see the defensive injuries to
her hands to her feet to her Palms to
her fingernails that she fought for her
life right according to what the doctor
said yes you'll have the jury believe
that Doug dri sat there and did all of
these things to his girlfriend while you
were just out cold on the lawn hanging
out I wasn't hanging out I'd been
knocked out from behind sir when I
didn't know anyone was behind me
actually you didn't say you were knocked
out from behind you you didn't remember
what happened you were having sex in the
next you knew you woke up on the ground
right it made me lead me to believe that
I had been knocked out because I didn't
pass out from standing there and then
you only recall just maybe a small
little bump on the back of your head I
remember being painful in the back of my
head not even a bump cuz that Jackson
would have seen that I'm 6'7 so it's
hard for someone to see the top of my
head when they're sitting on a boat
within 10 ft from you all afternoon that
I don't know sir what he saw two
theories one decision after 3 hours of
deliberations the jury decided if George
bur was in fact Nicole vanderheiden's
killer state of Wisconsin versus George
Steven Burch we the jury find the
defendant George Steven Burch guilty of
first-degree intentional homicide is
charged in the
information you felt the tension
everybody was there that had been
watching in terms of Nikki's family
Doug's family people that were familiar
with George and his story so once they
read read the guilty verdict um you just
heard it was just emotion it was pure
emotion the jury's verdict was not
terribly surprising his story did not
line up with the evidence and his story
was bide by things that are very
difficult to argue with namely DNA and
geolocation data George Burch was
sentenced to life in prison without
parole it's devastating you have
children that no longer have their
mother around very rarely does just a
complete stranger walk in and and murder
someone and a lot of times they're
sloppy and and there's evidence that
really will Zone in and pinpoint who
committed the crime I think law
enforcement in this case did an
excellent job they Ed the technology
piece they used the DNA piece to put all
this together that's going to give you
the best chance of getting that
conviction that you
want now the story didn't end there
because Burch appealed his case arguing
against how certain evidence was used in
his trial like the Fitbit data but in
the end the Supreme Court of Wisconsin
upheld his conviction what matters most
in this case though is not Burch it's
Nicole her family and loved ones have
spoken so passionately about her and you
can really understand who she was and
what she meant to those around her I do
want to leave you though with one quote
it happened during Birch's sentencing
where Douglas diet's mother Diane made a
statement and she said quote go home
today hug your loved ones tell them you
love them show them you love them that's
all we have for you here on Prime crime
thank you so much for joining us as
always and until next time stay
safe
[Music]